das heißt sonst wäre hier die ganze zeit
fragt julia big brother houston müssten
lösten meiner lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer neuen mut
vorstellung ich bin hier ganz normal in
einer welt allerdings irgendwas ist
anders ich glaube ich bin okay ich
glaube diese kleine szene zeigt schon zu
welcher mod ich heute euch heute euch
was ich stelle euch heute nämlich die
alpaka evolution revolution' alpaka
motto sag ich mal einfach vor wo ihr ein
alpaka werdet in minecraft und noch ein
wie halte ich denn manche meinen ich
halte mein schwert ja richtig komisch
ok ich halt das irgendwie so oder my
name ist ein bisschen verkrüppelt ich
weiß gerade nicht genau stellt euch auf
jeden fall heute die alpaka mord in
minecraft vor normalerweise wenn ihr
eine welt startet seid ihr noch keine
bagger ihr seid erst mal ein ganz
normaler mensch und mein gott hab ich
eine krippe hand ihr seid ein ganz
normaler minecraft skin und könnte noch
nicht richtig sein wie ein alpaka
beziehungsweise seht halt noch ganz
normal aus um einen packen ein alpaka zu
werden müsst ihr allerdings will er
töten und dann bekommt ihr von denen
gedroppt hat einerseits einerseits xp
und andererseits auch ein face und wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise in ingame ort
04 und sein falls es dann werde ich
nämlich eigentlich zum alpaka jetzt
sehen wir auch schon unten links moment
hier alpaka lips alpaka lippe apokalypse
okay jetzt bin ich nämlich eigentlich
erst ein richtiges alpaka habt ihr
natürlich meine tollen letter busan
sonst würde ich halt so hier aussehen
habe ich lass die mal an weil nicht das
mitteilt geht oder so und ihr seht schon
unten links habe ich das momentum das
momentum ist wenn ich jetzt ganz einfach
mal springen würde
seht ihr schon dass das lebt sich auf
und wenn ich jetzt springe springe ich
extrem hoch allerdings wenn man momentum
auf null springe ich nur so hoch und
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise ebner
hüpfen dann geht's halt immer wieder
zurück und geht halt höchstens bis eine
sekunde hoch und dann springe ich halt
immer wieder hoch und wenn ich halt
einfach so durchgedrückt lasse ist halt
komplett egal nach fünf sekunden ist es
egal höher kann ich nicht springen und
dann wäre es mir eigentlich theoretisch
auch möglich direkt auf den baum dort
hinten drauf zu springen genau und dann
bin ich auf dem baum drauf und wenn ich
jetzt hier warten möchte rein
theoretisch bis ich da irgendwie hoch
müsste ich erst mal sprinten und dann
das ist auf jeden fall das momentum ich
glaube das habt ihr kapiert jetzt fragt
ihr euch bestimmt hüllen luca bis sie
die ganze am sprinten und springen du
verlierst aber gar keinen hunger bald
was ist denn da los
ja und zwar wenn ich verliere keine
hunger balken allerdings wenn ich
trotzdem etwas essen möchte rein
theoretisch in meinem alpaka zustand
muss sich ein schwein zu setzen
beispielsweise dann sehen wir schon
liegt dort so ein körper vom schwein
wieso hat er sich gerade bewegt hier
erstmal schön den samen eingesammelt
hier vorne jetzt schön das essen
allerdings dieses essen wird mein ganz
normales hunger nicht auffüllen sondern
wir sehen hier das korps und da muss der
prächtig drauf klicken dann bekomme ich
nämlich direkt die xp die habe ich
direkt grad das hinbekommen und dadurch
habe ich das ganze jetzt gegessen ich
kann ich das noch mal kurz zeigen hier
bei dem anderen schreiben mit dem mit
den sounds und zwar hörte ich das mal an
und dann habe ich jetzt quasi dieses
schwein gegessen genau das gleiche ist
auch wenn ich kühe töte oder hühnchen
bei schafen bin ich mir nicht mehr
sicher durch ein 107 funktion spieler
allerdings ja doch auch hier ist es der
fall und dann sind das heißt quasi diese
corps heißen die also diese körper von
den teilen die liegen danach einfach rum
und die muss ich essen um mein hunger
aufzufüllen und diese teile hier kann
ich nicht essen also wenn ich die
rechtslücke muffins apple auch jetzt
kommt vollführt staub runtergefallen das
sind allerdings noch nicht alle
fähigkeiten wie das alpaka hat und zwar
kann nicht auch da zeige ich euch mal
wenn ich hier einfach doppelt f5 drücken
und wenn ich mich vor einem mob stelle
und einfach mal c drücke dann spreche
ich quasi die zunge aus und dann kann
ich das schwein mit mir ziehen ja
schweinchen und wenn ich dann
letztendlich sagen ich möchte die zunge
wieder drin haben kann ich einmal wieder
zu drücken und dann habe ich die fahne
wieder drin das schweinchen kann wieder
leben wenn ich wieder zurück kann ich
das quasi so einfach mitnehmen
ich kann dem schweinchen da glaube ich
nicht schaden mit zufügen ich bin mir
allerdings sehr unsicher ich meine aber
das ist so wie wenn ich irgendwie eine
angel oder so mache das macht keinen
schaden also doch hat gesehen dass
schweine stirbt davon nicht nichts
passiert mit dem schwein ich kann halt
damit ist es halt damit sinnvoller
irgendwie mops mitzunehmen für ihre
farben oder irgendwie sowas dass es ganz
cool kann man damit ganz gut machen und
jetzt meine lieben freunde gehen wir mal
auf den online server das sind nämlich
schon alle funktionen die eigentlich das
alpaka kanne zahl also hunger habe ich
euch gezeigt dann
m
das momentum habe ich euch gezeigt und
das lecken habe ich euch gezeigt okay
gut eigentlich nicht alles gezeigt wir
gehen jetzt mal auf den community server
und zwar wenn ich jetzt hier drauf bin
und beispielsweise drücke also das habe
ich natürlich wird schon mal gemacht aus
testzwecken haben wir überall alpakas
und jetzt wenig druck und auch vorstände
aufgehe sehen wir hier halt die skins
und diese skins sind also diese diese
ganz normalen minecraft skins und ganz
normal mein gott jetzt haben wir hier
die ganzen leute die hier mit einem
rumlaufen lasst mich doch ein paar mal
in ruhe
diese ganzen skins bzw namen die hier
sehen machen halt letztendlich den
alpaka farbcode den mann als alpaka hat
aus das heißt wenn ich jetzt drücke noch
vor streller anklicke seht ihr jeder hat
ihn wie eine andere farbe natürlich es
kommt farben doppelt werder vor oder so
allerdings es wird sich die farbe von
beispielsweise hier von massy die farbe
de ist rot habe ich gerade gesehen
die farbe von ihm oder meine farbe ist
ja auch roth meine farbe geht sich nicht
ändern solange ich nicht mal minecraft
username ändere das heißt sonst wird
hier die ganze zeit oder big brother
houston houston regale problem torfehler
kath.net einmal all but what the [ __ ]
die kommen einfach alle mit was passiert
wenn ich rein theoretische
rheinschwimmen gesetzt nicht wahr als ob
die jetzt wirklich das ist doch auf gott
freunde es ist so crazy aus über alan
parkers das ist unfassbar
das ist sowieso ein paar katze hält
wieso bin ich zum familienzelten jungen
girl you won't get me you won't get back
dir sein irgendwie alles schneller als
ich okay ich bin wieder mittendrin im
getümmel also das ist die alpaka motto
ihr könnt damit einfach um server gehen
und ihr habt nur ein pack als überall
und können die halt einfach schlagen
also das wird quasi der minecraft skin
mit in der setz durch ein alpaka und es
gibt spezielle andere fähigkeiten
eventuell fragt jetzt auch der ein oder
andere ob es auf servern auch möglich
ist mit der hilfe der c taste irgendwie
andere alpakas anzuziehen oder so dass
es allerdings nicht möglich weil
ja das wäre einfach nur total wie viele
fucking leute sind denn hier bitte dass
wir einfach nur so ein bisschen dumm
weil dann könnte ich ja quasi einfach
mops mit dem hinter herzen oder soll
sich trug grad c und es bewirkt nichts
und was außerdem nicht geht bzw was geht
ist es nicht - vorsichtig sehe ich da
nicht mal von vorne wenn ich es nicht
gehe ich halt ein bisschen runter
das hat man eventuell gerade gesehen
wenn sich da so sieht das dann aussieht
ganz cooler soll es bitte sich zu
formieren verbeugen so ein bisschen das
ist halt ganz night mit dem snacken und
sonst freunde wird mir das hier geht
alles ein bisschen zu stressig das in
viel zu viele leute die mich hier das
ist doch das kann doch nicht ich bin der
alpaka könig ja nein ich bin ja keine
freunde wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich über eine positive
bewertung freund schreibt mir doch in
die kommentare ob die alpakas mögt und
wenn ihr nein schreibt dann blockieren